today everybody we have four video game
trailers to watch we're gonna do Mortal
Kombat one
which just came out today and then Lords
of the Fallen which also just came out
today which from what we've seen before
I'm very very very excited about
uh and then the Five Nights at Freddy's
movie teaser which I'm also really
curious uh about I feel like that's been
anticipated for a long time now
I'm super interested in that movie and
then dead by daylight Nicholas Cage
um didn't see that coming
so first things first I have no idea why
this is called Mortal Kombat one
uh but I'm looking forward to it we're
watching this on the Warner Bros games
actual Channel
it's two minutes 30 seconds on and I'm
very excited to see how pretty it looks
let's do it
[Music]
time to wake up what a shot to a new
reality hmm
to a blank canvas that I have painted in
with warmth and peace
in my new era choice is yours I mean
this is beautiful but whether to live in
quiet serenity
or bloody strife
to dwell in joyous prosperity
[Applause]
all bitter rivalry
I love her so much
we can face each other
sworn enemies
or United as brothers Now give me chills
oh my God
but a storm
soon you will discover
that even in this new era
one constant reminder dude I
legitimately have Goosebumps
there is always something worth fighting
for
foreign
oh my God
you have chosen to defy peace
then you have chosen war with a god
oh my God
oh
[Music]
they didn't have to go that hard oh my
God that's so brutal
I feel like
I never love a trailer it's an
announcement trailer I get it they're
announcing the game they're clearly
announcing the tone which is Mortal
Kombat on crack very bloody very gory
um Mortal Kombat X I think it was I
worked a video game retailer in
Australia and it was uh like our first
r18 game if I remember correctly
um don't love that there's no gameplay
and we'll say that
and obviously every new Mortal Kombat
always looking at what everyone's
wearing and I do feel like some of the
fits here a little more basic than I
expected
um but
these first few kills
or are they like here
just we're just gonna watch these again
and probably get demonetized
Worth Fighting For
that oh my god dude
it's not just people getting downed and
knocked out you know just
torn apart oh my gosh
so brutal so I would guess that's
clearly a very hype reveal they clearly
hammering at home that this is a reboot
of the series which makes sense that's
all of the dialogue in that trailer is
all about that we probably get a
Gameplay trailer during not E3
um during summer games Fest
my gosh
Mortal Kombat at it again God damn
that was spicy yeah didn't have their
September 19 is really soon so we're for
sure gonna get gameplay really soon
which is cool can't wait to see it
goddamn um okay next Lords of the Fallen
Gameplay trailer aired this morning also
says blood and gore intense violence and
language
uh when we first saw this actually this
is also on Xbox because I think it's a
little like slightly extended
um when we first saw this I was like
dude hell yeah and I never played the
first game despite having it sitting on
my shelf for ages I was always like this
seems like something I would like but I
haven't played it
um
so
excited to jump into the franchise here
I'm down I hope this Trail is good
let's watch it
[Music]
more instead has fallen it's great to
Army decimated okay I just want to turn
my captions off by the legions of a deer
the demon god
but one light still flickers in the
ever-growing Gloom the light of the dark
crusader
bloodborne as hell dude
what is this bloodborne ass blood-borny
bloodborne you've got here
whoa if that's actual there's no way
it's gameplay
who's this tall King on the right
it is Darkness threatens to desolate our
world
ascends to Aureus my child
this is very cool
as his holy
in light we walk
isn't this supposed to be a Gameplay
trailer though you tell me this is uh
gameplay yeah come on now souls to Ash
[Music]
dude it's so so soulsy
I wonder what they're gonna do to make
it
the mark of the dark Crusaders
okay didn't expect this song
that's interesting great potential
dwells within your doubtless for you to
be chosen you're gonna need to tell me
how this is different from a Soul's game
is the only thing
oh it does look really good though
but you conscious
[Music]
that looks Doug
you grant me the strength to continue to
endure these dark days
sick design oh my God
[Music]
suffering hands
animations real sharp made a slave to
unceasing hunger
I pity you
the magic effects look sick recognize
the Blessed beacons of monstada and
thwart ideas
oh hello Market
I mean look
it looks very cool it does look very
Diablo
Souls
it me
13th of October 2023 reorder to unlock
exclusive Army tunics
um
look
it looks sick
but I would really want to know how it
differs from
uh forms of games essentially
not that it needs to be that different
but I feel like it's you kind of just
creatively just fully take something you
know
it's a little bit much
seems more story focused than from
schemes
I don't agree that it does I imagine it
will be
but I don't think it necessarily looks
more that way
like from stuff trailers just have that
much dialogue that don't necessarily
mean that much
a few people who love the first so much
I know it didn't hit that hard again I
own it it's on my shelf
um
but uh yeah never got around playing it
okay next
let's do Five Five Nights at Freddy's
this is the official teaser which has
been long awaited
um
I'm very excited to see what they do
with this I think Five Nights at
Freddy's is super fun in fact my next
stream I do if you haven't seen them
horror game streams with two horror
actresses Samsung and Kate Siegel I've
already asked if we can play Five Nights
at Freddy's
um I think it seems is super fun
I know a little bit about this movie
like I know that Freddy's here is shut
down
and I guess
your the protagonist is going into
security I don't know there's tons to
learn here I did see the posters they
revealed which I thought looked very
cool though not exactly what I expected
um so let's let's just jump right in
shall we I'm excited about this one I'm
so so curious what they're gonna do see
this is interesting because again we're
fantasy and fun come to life this has
got to just be a tone thing because
well okay no maybe that's just for
audiences who don't know about about
Freddy because the whole thing shut down
yeah
security guard
chicas
hello yeah
we're going to have so much fun together
this is definitely just a teaser trailer
whoa
[Applause]
oh man
information so fast hang on hang on yes
it is live action Scott the um
the
actual animatronics were made I believe
by uh what is it uh the Jim Henson
company is what it goes with
um there's so much that happened here so
I first this really stood out to me
where was it
the
these camera angles are like on point
like they're so similar to the game
that's really cool
and then I was like what's up with these
kids in the woods
so if you don't know anything about Five
Nights at Freddy's
they're all
possessed right
um
like this is probably Freddy and I we
haven't really delved into too much of
that that they're all possessed by
children effectively right so we saw
that yes they are dead kids so this this
the little girl who showed up is
probably gonna be like his sister or
something
and I wonder if there's gonna be like a
new
Freddie friend to occupy that's
obviously gonna be chica
um
and who's this
there's one more
just that nope come on
I wonder who that is am I missing
something
if I close them open for a second with
the white hat I don't know which one
that would be
maybe I haven't played all of the games
there are so many of them um
this is a really cool trailer though I'm
I'm really hoping this may be super
scary I'm super into it
it looks
very
cool uh
that's so good and there was a shot of
uh one of them
like opening up
I'm just gonna have to play it again
it's Freddy's newest security guard
it doesn't look really scary not
necessarily it's probably gonna be full
of jump scares I expect it to be more
creepy than than all-out scary
but with Justice right that so
I wonder who that is is that Freddy
probably
it looks like he's trying to basically
put him inside the UN returning and
that's how they like overtake them
is very sore like
I'm not sure who that woman is either
I don't know why I'm so excited about
this movie Just think it'll be really
fun
very fast trailer totally cool some
funny Strokes in there for sure
um
yeah it doesn't necessarily look super
scary definitely looks creepy and I
suspect it'll be full of jump scares
which is basically like exactly
uh what five minutes parties is so
coming out for Halloween is a Big W you
agreed I'm I'm looking forward to it
uh
okay
okay next up we have dead by daylight
Nicholas Cage teaser I have no idea what
to expect
Nicholas Cage is in dead by daylight I
think is the insinuation let's take a
look
I'm curious
it is his actual voice
oh my gosh
shade the fabric of reality this is live
action for me everything you may think
you know
foreign
[Music]
dude dead by daylight just pops off oh
my gosh learn more on July 5th
but you know what's hilarious I don't
know if he's a hero or a villain
amazing that's super fun he's a villain
is he let's see if it says in the
comments anywhere
Nicholas caves arrival in the fog
hello survivors etc etc
oh literally just the exact same thing
I love this is straight up Nicholas Cage
not one of his characters good about our
evil it's just him yeah
that's so funny
that's super fun man
um
that's it for today's trailer reactions
everybody I'm gonna start doing them in
bulk more often all of these look really
cool to me I Mortal Kombat 1 would like
to see gameplay of course never loved
cinebank trailer I think it looks brutal
as hell though Delight to watch Lords of
the Fallen also look very cool but a
little bit too familiar unfortunately I
would love to see how it stands out Five
Nights at Freddy's obviously just a
teaser I wonder when we're gonna get the
full trailer get a bit more story
context um but a fun series of Easter
eggs if I like frame by frame that I'm
sure I'll find some more fun stuff dead
by daylight very simple
always a good time always a good time
looking forward to seeing more from all
of these things